I've got a voicemail for you today that
I suspect I will have viewers and
listeners who will not like this
voicemail and it is a caller speaking
some difficult truths to a sliver or a
slice of the left let's take a listen to
it progressive media is really risking
jumping the shark right now they're
covering stories like the George Bush
story and they seem to not understand
that people who do wrong things in the
past can occasionally still be
correcting statements they made and
they're also covering the story with
Jill Biden saying that we told you so
Bernie Sanders would beat the president
no he wouldn't
Bernie Sanders couldn't even win the
Democratic nomination and it wasn't the
DNC's fault this time the people did not
like Bernie Sanders they like Joe by.ya
okay so let's listen let's deal with
that second issue first I've already
discussed the the Bernie a Biden thing
you know to assume that Bernie obviously
would defeat Trump in November but Biden
won't ignores essentially all of the
facts that we have including that Bernie
lost the Democratic primary by millions
of votes and that that number may climb
as more primaries are done via mail-in
ballot I don't think we need to address
that again on the issue of the bush
story what the caller is referring to is
that over the weekend George W Bush put
out a three-minute video where he says
the corona virus is serious it's not the
time for partisanship we need to come
together etc it's a completely
reasonable and accurate message
it doesn't mean Bush was right to go
into Iraq it doesn't mean Bush was right
with the torture it doesn't mean
anything about Bush other than he was
right about that and he's more sensible
than Trump on this issue and I covered
this yesterday and I had already been
getting attacked on Twitter for it over
the weekend and I got attacked again for
rehabilitating the reputation of a war
criminal etc etc and what I've realized
if I've had it sort of an epiphany over
the
last ten days and I'm gonna tell you
what it is right now what we've got a
couple minutes here before we wrap the
show so I'll tell you what it is
I always tended to just do the show the
way I want to do it and do the stories I
want to do and so on and so forth but
every once in a while a little bit of
calculation would enter in where I might
say I need to moderate my language here
or there or whatever because I risk
getting a certain reaction from my
audience which I would seek to to avoid
I'm not really paying any more attention
to that because no matter what I do that
backlash is going to exist in case in
point yesterday I literally said during
my segment about hey george w bush was
right about this one thing right this
should not be a partisan thing the
corona virus we've got to come together
Trump is wrong on it
I said twice in the segment Bush is a
war criminal I called the statement a
completely unremarkable milquetoast
statement and yet it still shows us how
wacked Donald Trump is on this and every
other issue that he can't even put out a
normal statement one time which George W
Bush was able to do didn't matter didn't
call them a war criminal twice in the
segment and people are saying David you
are ignoring the fact that this guy's a
war criminal and real rehabilitating his
image I called him a war criminal twice
during the segment so what I've clearly
realized is when people say David you
should cover this or you shouldn't cover
that or here's the position you have to
do it actually doesn't matter it all if
people have determined that I'm the
enemy if they want to be mad at me
they're going to be regardless of what I
say if I cover a story if I don't cover
or whatever so if you see any change in
the show over the next couple of weeks
other than the fact that we've extended
the show an additional 10% every day the
show is longer now which is beautiful
it's a fantastic thing you will see that
I will be paying even I was paying 8%
attention before call it to what I
expected the reactions to be to how I
take on issues that's going down to zero
some people will like it some people
will not but alas such is life we've got
a great bonus show for you today become
a member at join pakman.com do not miss
today's
bonus show it will be a particularly
good one